speaking of tyranny now is a good
opportunity to talk about a horrifying
story if it loads probably there we go
oh this this is scary oh man yeah you're
not kiddin
government contact tracing app sends
user data to Foursquare and Google why
yeah good question so apparently this is
a North Dakota there is a new contact
tracing app they've been using and it is
sending your private data to private
companies and there's even an argument
its contact monetization because the
data can be sold and used whoa
so this is from futurism comm and it
gives us kind of like a quick summary of
a couple different articles so I'll just
read this to you and then we can talk
about we can carry on our conversation
about yeah do we even have rights at
this point public access they report
there's a troubling flaw with the
coronavirus contact tracing app used in
North Dakota it violates its own privacy
policy by quietly sending users
information to companies like Foursquare
now I'll just I'll stop real quick you
guys some context frozen are familiar
contact tracing is this idea that say
your phone when might when I when I walk
up to Adam my phone knows his phone and
so it records the the contact and then
governments can look at who talks to who
to try and figure out where the virus
may have spread from how convenient so
now they want all these people to
download this app so that they can look
on a map and see who talked to who and
every like it's that's insane you know
sane spine right insane to make it so so
they tell us it's for your safety you
know there's a virus man if you get sick
we want to know how you got second who
you came to contact with right that
makes sense and they go and sell your
data to a private third-party company
and what are they gonna do with it yeah
that seems like a sneaky way they were
able to get access to our private
information oh good and now we're seeing
this consumer privacy app company jumbo
studied the app care 19 and found that
it was transmitting information to third
parties including Foursquare and Google
according to the Washington Post the
finding is unfortunate not only because
it's a major privacy violation but also
because it threatens to erode the
public's trust in government attempts to
contain kovat 19 and then that and the
public is already lost trust for a lot
of reasons
proud kraut here's this contact
monetization proud crowd the company
that developed the contact tracing app
confirmed that it sends data but says
it's not for commercial purposes
according to Oppo and a Foursquare
spokesperson told wopo they don't use
that data and it's promptly discarded
but the fact remains that Kara 19 users
were told their data wouldn't be sent
out at all yeah but they're they said
they were selling it to them though
selling it to third party it says
selling no no no trends I thought they
said in the first the first one thing
you wrote her read no it's sending it to
oh sending it okay well like
monetization no not selling well that's
no they write it just says contact
monetization okay listen listen okay I
don't care what they said you know why
you're right yeah remember uh Cambridge
analytic oh yeah don't worry your data
will be discarded and then we'll sell it
to a private company to harvest voter
data through using political campaigns
so now think about what they can do with
all this data they don't just know who
you talk to they know where you go yeah
think about this way if if you are in
you know your downtown in your city and
I come into contact with Adam then you
know thirty minutes later I come in
contact with Lydia in the southwest
suburbs they now basically know the most
likely route I took where I went
you know the time it took for you to get
there they know if I was speeding in my
car they're gonna be like that's
interesting
in order to it should have taken you an
hour to get there but you got there in
45 minutes you must been going pretty
fast huh
no break you know they can also see if
it took longer they can make must have
stopped for food then it's not even
about who I know they would have been
able to tell where he said exactly yeah
yep because I won't even know Bill
Johnson who's getting a cheeseburger at
Carl's jr. but I pulled up to the
drive-thru and he was in front of me and
that's that we don't know something he
touched or whatever the range is for the
cell phones right and now they know
exactly where I stopped because everyone
and they're gonna see clusters in the
map and then here's the best part now
they're gonna tell us for us to us it's
better just atom trust me I'm not gonna
send your data to private companies to
sell liddie you want to buy Adams data
sure yeah
I don't like this why do you want my
information Lydia she wants to know what
you get you to get you for your birthday
it's true she wants to know where I got
my sweatshirt so let's hear that's real
bit more they say quote sharing is
supposed to be an anonymous code along
with an advertising identifier has Syria
sharing what is supposed to be an
anonymous code along with an advertising
identifier has serious privacy risks why
would there be an advertising identifier
at all yeah why this is just exist it's
exactly what you'd expect man come on
if listen if the government came and
said we just want to know who you've
been talking to it has nothing to with
anything don't worry about it and you're
like okay yeah yes sir
yes sir okay sir yeah lawyer whatever
you say sure yeah if they you you will
be advised by any lawyer worth their
weight do not talk to any law
enforcement without a lawyer
period yeah meddler that's not advice
for me it's just what I was told i watch
a youtube video once only said yeah well
if you heard it on the inner but
thinking about the data the government
is asking for with you having without
having a warrant without having even
talks to legal you know uh
representation or anything right and
then think about what they might say if
there's a lockdown and they go according
to the app you were in the park remember
that dude in Hawaii got arrested because
he took selfies no some dear mother some
dude went to Hawaii and then he merely
went out and took selfies and was having
a good time
okay police saw the pictures on social
meet our people saw the pictures
reported him cops came and arrested him
and they said it's a 14 day quarantine
as soon as you come and because you took
these pictures we know where you were
you under arrest
Wow there was an apparently another
woman same thing happened to I just saw
the story earlier today that she like
post itself is in the beach and the
beach is closed or something so they
went and found her and so think about
contact tracing you know you walk
through Central Park not realizing it's
closed and then they come and arrest you
the park was closed the scary world with
it'll give you a ticket
yeah I don't like this at all bro it's
coming it's good it's it's gonna be you
know I mean it's coming it's here
they're doing it
I mean widespread national everyone's
gonna be happy and like oh I got my
connection yet now the government knows
where I am great perfect you know you
know think about like think about living
in the 1800s and I'm like watching these
old westerns and stuff and I'm like
what's to stop some dude from just
killing literally anybody in than
getting away with it
yep my mind goes to Red Dead Redemption
to you right going down the road you see
someone boom no you throw ground who
would know no one would know and no one
does know and you just keep riding and
you're gonna mean to be honest a lot of
people don't know this is kind of scary
I believe the overwhelming majority of
premeditated murder has never solved Wow
never so really yep most murders that
are solved their passion crimes but yeah
it's the ones that aren't well planned
for MIDI it's that's scary dude you know
it's really scary it's like it's like a
small percentage I think it's actually
decent enough though like premeditated
murder it's like you know I think it's
like 40 percent or something gets solved
that's still not very high actually no
no I think I'm wrong I think I'm wrong
okay I think it's way less way way less
yeah yeah look it up look it up because
it's something I heard a really really
long time ago
yeah Wow that like I think it was
passion murders actually have a less
than less than chance likelihood of
being you know solved Wow there's a 40%
chance to get away with murder
something something free money in
America yep police it's all rate is even
worse for other crimes if you murder
someone in America there's nearly 40%
chance so get away with it okay so it's
a 60% chance they'll find him is that
specifically premeditated or they
combining all different kinds of murder
oh yeah FBI's latest data on crime yeah
that's that makes more sense what you're
saying then yeah well what right
premeditated right well know the passion
like passion murders they solve right of
course the total number of murders wait
I think they finally exactly higher
right so if they actually I'm curious if
that actually tracked only premeditated
because sure because this I remember
being told this I don't know if it's
true it's been a long long time that it
takes only a little bit of obfuscation
or reader misdirection tooth
court investigation sure and so it's you
know that's that's scary I guess
actually it's an argument for contact
tracing because then it's like you turn
up dead yeah and they're like an
argument yeah well actually no no I mean
that's what that's why I brought it up
I'm like you think about the technology
back then and it was like someone you
could be taking a leak behind the saloon
and someone to lock up and go bang and
they walk away and that's it what me
yeah it's like you probably think that
it's the same back then they passion
passion murders are probably the ones
they solved yeah well who hated this
person well Johan Johan sanad over here
he hated him and go with her he's like
washing the blood off his hand like no I
said we got you ha ha yeah pretty much
it I guess what's scary for back then is
the likelihood of innocent people being
locked up was substantially higher you
know even going back a few decades we
have innocent people in prison and then
DNA evidence it's probably still
happening yeah definitely that's why I
oppose the death penalty man you hear
that story I'm gonna be very very vague
with the language here okay there's a
story of a guy who he wrote this long
message
he confessed to murder because he saw a
guy in his neighborhood who was did some
bad things to kids right and he looked
him up saw saw that he was like I was
and he killed the guy Wow and people are
cheering for him he's a wreck raising it
oh I know it money I this is right now
right yeah right now I know you're
talking about yeah yeah so this guy like
people on Twitter like he's a hero he's
a hero and all the stuff they're raising
a bunch of money for him and I'm like
for me it's kind of like man I mean he
murdered still murdered somebody
I am bethy's like this dude is his bad
like wow the guy's you didn't kill the
guy the guy who got killed was convicted
13 years ago okay the challenge is
innocent until proven guilty and so if
this guy got convicted 13 years ago then
what you need to do is prove it but I
bring this up because you know if if
we're dealing with the use of technology
to prove innocence and stuff we have to
we have to recognize the fact there are
many people who are locked up who didn't
do anything wrong
and then if you think you know we can
kill people then the argument I hear
from people is often I'm I'm okay with
killing one innocent person out of X if
it means we get rid of bad people and
I'm like man I could not imagine being
an innocent person all you have to do is
be like sacrifice would you be that
innocent person yeah some people say yes
question yeah I don't think everyone
could say yes though in that situation
though do you want to be the sacrifice
to make them work I don't want any
innocent people killed no I just mean
like right word I'm not saying oh you
know if it is better than ten guilty
persons escape than one innocent person
suffer and I think Ben Franklin said is
better than 100 guilty persons escape
and one innocent sufferer and I'm like I
completely agree with it argue that yeah
it's a challenge though because people
turn it around and say what if that one
murderer who gets released murders
another person and now an innocent
person has suffered yeah that's a really
important point to bring up it is a good
point man conundrums and that that
brings me back to the contact tracing
argument because now you come back to
the security versus freedom if this
contact tracing app can be used in a
bunch of different ways it could stop
murderers well I mean it feels like they
could do that without giving our data to
private company right right that's the
problem that's the line one I'm like
okay whoa like what are you doing giving
our information away like you know you
want to use it you want to use it for
this now obviously they're already using
it so well I well I agree but my line is
giving the government access to know
where I am at all times well I agree I
don't want them to have that information
anyway it's like you but they have it
like like our body we've already given
all our contact data to Facebook so it's
like for me to sit here and be like Oh
har um I already know when I'm pooping
you know now now I feel like every time
I poop I get this urge to just tweet at
Facebook like hey Facebook you don't
open right now you know what I want I
want to take you know that you know the
Kilroy meme was here I want to make that
but it's Mark Zuckerberg and I want to
put the decal in the bathroom there
there's like a Zuckerberg face like that
peeking out of RO wall gross over a big
Facebook logo or or underneath in the
toilet bowl you know be funny no no no
you know just public restroom installs
Oh
like here or you can have you have like
some sort of machine that when you sit
down as soon as it senses that someone
sitting down it comes up from oh no it's
just an ad for something well if you had
if you had a sticker you could easily
just be like you know on the inside of a
stall and people because people walk in
when people walk into stalls they don't
look at it yeah so you walk in they
close it they turn then they sit down
and look up and it's like looking down
maybe with like a magnifying glass and
an award bubble says I'm watching you
poop or no no I'm sorry I know you're
pooping I know you're grouping now but
then you can alright we got it
talk to me later
oh of course you took the camera away no
luck to me later it would be an
excellent informational campaign to
explain to people about what it means
when you're giving up your privacy it's
true but hold on let me ask you then is
it really that big of a deal if
Zuckerberg knows you're pooping I
thought about that too because we've
talked about them knowing when I poop a
lot and I'm just like Facebook have at
it
so my pooping times too so let's talk
purses security okay what if you're
pooping mm-hmm and then you're straining
really hard and like an embolism pops in
your brain and then you collapse and
then faceplant picture in it Facebook's
tracking light and so Facebook's
predictive model is like okay he should
be in the bathroom for you know about a
minute and then he should get up and he
should go to Taco Bell like normal but
then you don't think a Cobell yes one
man they know it all it takes your phone
isn't moving
they're like hello and then it
calculates the probability and then it
says in all likelihood Adam was injured
and then they call 9-1-1 and the
ambulance shows up and there you are
keeled over in your bathroom with like
one eye bloodshot and you're like and
they save your life yeah I hate that
actually happened so where's the guy sir
yes so there was a guy who was riding a
mountain bike and he like went over the
handlebars yeah he was wearing his Apple
Fitness watch or whatever and they were
like oh my gosh just suddenly stopped
and then
stopped moving completely and so they
sent paramedics to his location because
of course they had his location Wow yeah
it's kind of cool though kind of yeah
well that's a perfect example of where
it's a good thing that I don't know how
hurt he was well the guy what about that
movie 48 hours dude broke his arm
without like yeah you got pinned in you
know and yet he actually saw his arm off
and what got out I don't know I haven't
seen the movie but I know that's what
it's about it's a real story his arm i
right III thought there was a movie or
like a story about a guy who was had a
tree fall on his leg and then he pulled
out a pocketknife and then you just like
but but back to what you were talking
about though the security versus freedom
infringement yeah our freedom and
security I guess I guess theoretically
your freedom you know you can when it
comes to having your data tracked in
certain ways yeah it's possible you're
not gonna give up any freedom maybe a
little bit but gained a lot more
security older people right exactly yeah
cuz they detected a an arrhythmia for
another lady Wow yeah yeah
she had atrial fibrillation and they
were watching her heart like usual and
they were like holy cow it's really
irregular and it's really fast because
it gets up into like 140 sometimes it's
really really I mean you'll be sitting
there doing absolutely nothing in your a
chair just fibrillating so what she had
like a Fitbit on or something yeah she's
wearing her again like her i watch oh
okay so I was like that that could be
useful for some people right Mark
Zuckerberg is our friend we should love
Facebook hold on wait a minute
what beanie you got on Facebook while
the camera was changed someone took like
a little computer chip Tim blink three
times if it's you yeah there is an
interesting a problem with just general
freedom versus security in a broader
sense wait you just blink three times oh
my god
I'm blinking I'm blinking SOS feels good
no like I'm not another way to look at
it is like ATM ATMs yet thanks
yeah like the monopolization of banks is
a bad thing you know these big banks
then become too big to fail then they
start panicking
to cause major economic collapse like in
2008 but it is pretty convenient you
know nowaday how nowadays how you can go
anywhere and see and find an ATM because
there's only a few banks true it's like
there's a convenience to having that one
ubiquitous service but a major detriment
than to them being too powerful and then
being unable to stop and then when they
when they screw things up they bag and
the government has to bail them out
so it's like maybe the convenience isn't
really worth it
I mean competition is really important
and we're losing that to true but but
anyway back to the contact racing stuff
it's it's it's convenience is a really
easy way to steal freedom yeah yeah but
in the same sense it's like ATMs is
convenient for us what do we get out of
this contact tracing stuff like what
what is it really giving us it unless
you're old
public-health right yeah oh okay right
let's entertain their actual argument if
there was a serious outbreak I mean
there is right I mean a more serious one
like you you know some kind of like
something or good work or something okay
then it would be great actually that's
the scary thing because we're you know
it's what I was talking about with like
population growth I mean we've got real
adversaries right mm-hmm and it's it's
the the challenge is knowing where the
line needs to be drawn and when security
needs to be it needs to override certain
things you know it's not as it's not as
easy to say you know absolute in any
direction now I definitely think we want
a vir I always veer towards freedom for
sure because power tends to corrupt
absolute power tends to corrupt
absolutely yeah you give someone
emergency powers what do they do they go
Witmer on you they was queen Karen let's
let's turn that into a thing going wit
Marilyn Whitmer here yeah she would have
to rode a 70 year old barber I know but
look at look at governor Murphy he's
like these two young men running a gym
oh I'll get you it's like I'm gonna
bring the full force of the law down on
you in your sewer system big conspiracy
conspiracy you know but I mean oh no but
the governor directly threatened them
saying it's like this is not a game like
we will you know come after you it's
like yeah life isn't a game they want to
support their families that's what
they're thinking and they're not the
only gen they're not trying to play
games yes that's that's that's the main
problem is that you can't expect
the convenience offered to to be used
properly as we've seen with this contact
tracing app they can whisper all the
sweet nothings into your ears about how
if you if you if you you know you're in
your living room you think you had a
fart then you pop it up you know vein in
your brain and you collapse will save
you if you fall off your bike or
whatever will be there for you it all
sounds good
yeah sure those few and far between
stories of where it actually does make
sense like okay yeah what about how how
about you know exactly what every single
person is doing and you're giving it to
private inform you know yeah yeah making
mother also think about how they could
they could come after you for anything
like I said like the guy who would be
you're speeding yeah yeah watching that
you get a ticket in the mail yeah so
okay so this is something that I noticed
when I use Google Maps is that they'll
tell you what the speed limit is here
and then right beside it is your speed
right really gives you your speed now I
was like this is how they're gonna get
us they'll just send you the ticket in
the mail yo Wow you know what the big
problem with this is because III did an
interview this guy named Moxie
Marlinspike okay hey miss like data
privacy you know technologists and
people often say what's the big deal if
I'm not doing anything wrong I got
nothing to worry about right and his
response was no because think about the
legalization of marijuana across the
country okay it's illegal federally how
would we know we want it legal unless
someone broke the law if they always
know what you're doing then the only
thing that can happen is more laws will
be created and laws will never be
repealed right moving further and
further towards authoritarian exactly
that's the danger of spying on people
because people need to be able to bend
and break and and and you know and
change these laws now now we just saw I
think you know in Virginia they just
signed a bill decriminalizing marijuana
okay I'm sure there's a lot of people
don't like it um there a lot of states
that have legalized it but it's a
relatively popular thing I mean I'm
convinced that if Trump came out right
now and said it said something like
we're gonna legalize marijuana across
this country federally we're gonna tax
it to me great biggest landside never it
would just be like young people we have
out first like well Trump's winning
chunk up Biden go home yeah I go back to
the old home that you're obviously
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you